I don't buy processed cereals for my children
because they're filled with ingredients
that I don't consider food.
They've been processed and refined in the lab
and loaded with sugar and glycosate
sprayed flour.
Cinnamon Toast Crunch cereal will light up the nucleus
acumbent region of the brain like a Christmas tree,
creating a drug like effect.
Surge of dopamine creates addiction
and the incredible desire for more sugar.
Ever been able to stop at just one small bowl?
There's a reason for that.
It's not our children's fault for bad behavior,
learning disabilities,
yo yo. Mood swings are unhealthy,
weight gain when they're fed these types of food.
When I make wheat products for my family,
I always use eincorn
because it's the oldest form of wheat
still in its original form.
Today's modern wheat has been hybridized,
thus the gluten is much higher
and it has a different genetic makeup,
causing many kids
and adults to have gluten intolerances.